roger highfield has written seven books
you can read about them online they've
had fantastic reviews he has a website
and he's also tweets at roger highfield
he's also a science journalist and
broadcaster born in wales raised in
north london he was
for two decades 20 years uh science
editor of the daily telegraph and he is
now editor of the new scientist ladies
and gentlemen roger highfield thank you
thank you
gosh
i did actually want to tweet this event
you'll be shocked to hear but of course
there's no signal here is a bit
depressing shows you the limits of
modern technology now i'm going to start
off with a kind of nerdy point what do
we mean by technology i found one
definition it said you know making usage
knowledge of tools techniques crafts
systems or methods of organization in
order to solve a problem
and i really just want to
think of it in a very general way it's
putting understanding to some kind of
use
now
thinkers as diverse as freud as engels
as thomas carlisle once thought that the
use of tools
was a defining
behavior of human beings but actually
technology is millions of years old
and i don't really you know this idea
that it's unnatural or it's human it's
quite wrong you know when an ostrich
drops a rock on an egg to break it uh
sorry when that when an egyptian vulture
i beg your pardon uh drops in a rock on
a on an ostrich egg to break it open
that's the use of a tool
if you observe wild chimpanzees you can
see them using tools for all kinds of
foraging purposes
um they've got
they've got probes to get up to
termites
they use leaves to drink
water
they use stones to as anvils and so on
um throw rocks at each other and so on
uh
cracking nuts so this is all tool use
you can see it in capuchin monkeys and
so on
dolphins female bottlenose dolphins
teach their
offspring how to use sponges to rummage
around in the seabed and so on
my personal favorite is the new
caledonian crow
which are really uh cool animals
actually they're almost human-like in
the use of tools
earlier studies about 10 years ago show
that the
the tool use of these crows where
they're ripping out these pandanus
leaves and using them to get out bugs
and things like that
matched uh human tool use about two and
a half million years ago to about 700
000 bc
but the kind of anthropocentric within
us
would argue that only humans had the
brainpower to evolve technology but in
fact if you go to new caledonia this
island in the pacific you will see as
good evidence that the crows have
evolved
to use so
with those evolving leaf tools i think
the birds are well and truly levered man
off his pedestal so i'd argue that
technology's been around for millions
and millions
of years
um and so for the purpose of this debate
i'm going to say that modern technology
is anything invented by humans so let's
start off with fire that was something
we understood how to use
probably used by uh homo erectus
something like half a million years ago
to uh you know originally maybe goes
back as far as a million years ago
with fire that opened up extraordinary
opportunities for mankind and if you
talk to richard wrangham an academic at
harvard university he actually says it's
linked with being human
he argues the point at which our bodies
show an adaptation to cooking goes back
a couple of million years ago
and you can see evidence
um in the changes that took place uh
when we evolved from ancestors that like
chimpanzees that already standing
upright
by cooking we could absorb more energy
that meant that we could invest less
effort into getting intestines more
effort in growing our brains
it affected our brain because humans
became socialists they worked around the
campfire and so on and if you look at
rangan's argument it's pretty clear that
the this particular technology the use
of fire actually helped make us
human
so i'd argue that modern technology has
actually made us
who we are
and i want to just go to something that
brendan raised
uh you know the effect of this modern
technology is very profound indeed i
mean how many people here are over
35 years old if you dare admit it put
your hands up well obviously if you look
through the history you know of human
cultures you find life expectancy at
birth in the stone age was a miserable
20 so you'd all pretty much be dead if
we were back in the stone age
uh if you go to classical greece life
expectancy was about 28
early modern britain 25 to 40 early 20th
century 50 to 65
uh and now the life expectancy at birth
of the world
is about 67 uh years
and you can see a very clear link
between how old people get in the
pervasiveness of technology in society
and certainly during the industrial
revolution you could see the percentage
of children the life expectancy of
bigger partner children increased
dramatically so the percentage in london
so you died before the age of five
decreased from three quarters
uh from 1730 to 1749 to about a third in
1810 to 1829
so
you know it's very clear that technology
has had a huge effect on how long we're
living and i think there's also it's
pretty clear that things are getting
better
as well
if you look at the proportion of the
developing world's population living in
extreme economic poverty that fell
from 1990 from 28
to 21 in 2001.
so things are
not only are there many more of us
than there ever was you know the the uh
the population is predicted to be about
7 billion and only well relatively
speaking 1.7 billion i wouldn't say only
obviously you want to get it down to
zero living in absolute poverty
but really there are more people around
than ever before living in more
in better conditions and for longer than
ever before now
of course the whole message of this
early use of fire is that it gives you
responsibility once you could learn how
to use fire to sterilize your food to
keep warm and so on you also have the
opportunity to burn down your neighbors
hut or whatever
or to burn their crops
so it's always given us this
responsibility
in fact uh just for a kind of terrible
book plug but in my latest book super
co-operators with martin novak a harvard
academic we argue that we've got a great
propensity to cooperate with each other
and
we've got this incredible responsibility
from technology but i'm confident that
we're actually it we know we're
programmed in various ways to to think
that we can put it to better use not
worse you so just to summarize i'd say
technology actually made us
human and modern technology has only
created one problem and that is how to
handle the incredible responsibility
that the power of technology gives us
and that's it basically
thank you very much roger
and now
the speakers for the motion that's
brenda o'meal and harry ayers your
witness
um
roger it seems to me you were talking
mainly almost exclusively about old
technologies um in yours in your speech
nearly all of which i agreed with but
you were talking about the benefits yeah
but remember you know technology goes
back to millions of years i reckon
modern humans go back to a couple
hundred thousand years so i would say
that's very modern technology indeed
actually relative to millions of years
of technology use
yeah come on give me a break yeah
remember to speak it straight into the
mind thanks go ahead do you not
recognize that there is a profound
difference between an animal dropping a
rock onto an egg
and human technology do you not like it
do not appreciate that though what an
animal is doing is instinctive what
humans are doing
in fact there's beautiful evidence of
chimpanzees
washing
rocks and washing food i'm trying to
remember what it was now in in japan
um there was a colony of that you can
actually see cultural evolution in
chimpanzees there's a big debate if you
talk to andy white and
uh and saint andrews uh he'll explain
how there's lots of evidence that
chimpanzees have culture just as rich as
ours where one individual learns how to
do a trick and by observation other
individuals do that trick as well so i
think you you guys are suffering from an
incredibly
limited myopic picture of what we mean
by technology i feel sorry for you gotta
open your minds come on um
going back to this point and you were
talking about life expectancy increasing
which of course we're all grateful for
but by far the greatest influence on
that was clean water which didn't
involve any particularly sophisticated
technology and again i don't feel that
you're really addressing this question
of new technology
i would disagree with that in fact i
mean you know i think learning uh a
profound there was a profound change in
human culture when we learned to
live in cities and that really
bootstrapped
human
cultural evolution but one of the
problems we had was because we were
polluting our own water and actually
just the application of things like
learning how to make tea boiling water
to sterilize it or making weak beer so
you're a beer culture if you're european
those were i would say that is
technology that's applying knowledge to
solve a very difficult problem indeed
all right very quickly very quickly yeah
the old technology definitely improved
human life but new technology is making
it worse because new technology in the
third world now is sustainable
technology like solar power and burning
cow [ __ ] in order to keep yourself warm
which is not going to improve anyone's
life so surely the new technology which
people support
which they they doll up as sustainable
development is not a good thing you'll
get your turn out there i
profoundly disagree with that i i think
um you know those sorts of appro
appropriate technologies are incredibly
important to give people a quality of
life technology appropriate to being in
poverty
well i think it's appropriate to how
many resorts how much resources you can
get
if stone age man had had appropriate
technology we'd all still be living in
caves we want inappropriate technology
which breaks through barriers
well i think the modern internet ages
are wonderful
you know
ultra modern technology that breaks all
barriers and i'm not sure why you're
moaning about all this pancreas so i
want to be flattered and pampered and
have a lovely okay we gotta wrap it up
thank you very much